نحن في الغابه دي بنشتغل تجارب عشان كده
بنكون محددين عدد اللقطات اللي احنا
عايزينها من كل يعني تجربه من التجارب او
من كل الاشجار
نحن الان مشاهدينا وصلنا الى غابه الدمكيه
وهي اكبر غابه بحثيه موجوده في ولايه شمال
كردفان هذه الغابه هي
اكبر غابه بحثيه انشات لاغراض البحث
العلمي لانتاج الصمغ العربي نحن الان في
موسم
الحصاد
وهذه اشجار الهشاب في هذه المنطقه التي
زرعت قبل سنوات لتنتج كميات من الصمغ
العربي
نحن الان امام شجره الهشاب واحده من
الاشجار المنتجه للصمغ العربي واللي هي
الاكيشيا السنغال
معروفه هنا في شمال كردفان والصمغ وطبعا
معروف في منطقه شمال كردفان او كردفان
بصوره عامه بانه الصمغه الكردفاني معروفه
عالميا لانه بيتميز بمناخ مختلف تماما من
حيث التربه ودرجه الحراره والرطوبه
فانتاجوا عالي فانتهت مرحله الطق ونحن
بدينا مرحله الله او اللي هو حصاد الصماء
العربي فالان ما شاء الله ان احنا شايفين
الصمغ يعني موجود في الشجره بصوره واضحه
جدا وهو تحديد ال45 يوم من التاريخ الطج
اول لقطه عشان يكون حجم الكعكول معقول
ويسموه زي نضج يعني بالنسبه لي ده بنسميه
ونحن الكعكول يعني فبيكون نضج وبيكون جاهز
لانه للحصاد يعني
لزق جدا
من الجلد البقر مثلا
قربوا عليه لانه ده قريب بشيل بلقب باليد
ده القطب اليد
شيلو بالراحه بيجمعوا واخطه في البتاع ده